et puisque je parle de réseau et je
parle de mobilité
je voulais vous dire que le plan de
relance portera une attention
particulière aux pistes cyclables on m'a
manqué quand j'ai dit ça on a dit il
parle d'un gadget
pas du tout mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs pas du tout pas du tout
le vélo c'est bon pour l'environnement
c'est bon pour la santé
et nous sommes à une révolution c'est le
vélo électrique
il va multiplier les usages il va
multiplier les usages il va raccourcir
les distances oui oui mesdames et
messieurs oui mesdames et messieurs ne
riez pas ne riez pas dans dix ans dans
dix ans on pourra si on fait un réseau
de pistes cyclables sécurisées on pourra
aller de prades à perpignan un vélo pour
aller travailler
oui ça c'est concret ça c'est concret et
c'est ce qui va se passer et je vous le
dis mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
les jeunes générations attendent cela
oui tout ceci tout ceci vous paraît
secondaire
tout ceci vous paraît secondaire
peut-être c'est un sujet essentiel c'est
aussi un sujet concret les gens vont
comprendre cela
les gens vont comprendre cela et c'est
une bonne façon de faire de l'écologie
et du développement durable à la portée
de tous et de toutes
je savais que ce sujet plairait beaucoup
à l'empt assemblée sur le président
robin ercis
[Musique]